hello everyone recently a student posted
a comment in one of my videos expressing
his grievance on the restriction that
jay advanced can be attempted only twice
he also asked my stance about it
through this video i will put forward
some points which can perhaps help to
create a better understanding of this
restriction please note that although
i'm an iit faculty the points that i'm
going to put forward
are based purely on my own personal
thoughts and opinions
and perhaps less in my capacity as an
iit faculty and more in my capacity as
an ex-iitn because i was an
undergraduate student here in the
mechanical engineering department of iit
kharagpur and
back in our time
no such restrictions were there so i
have the advantage of seeing firsthand
what happens in the absence of these
restrictions so earlier when no such
restrictions were there
what used to happen was that
many students used to come to iit after
attempting iitg as it was called then
three times sometimes even four times
perhaps even more
as a result what used to happen was that
in the same batch on the one hand
we would have students who were fresh
out of their plus two
at max they have dropped one year and uh
they had attempted itj twice and come to
iit
so they were quite fresh and young
and on the other hand we had some older
guys who had attempted three times four
times and then come to iit
so
this kind of a situation
was
creating some kind of an imbalance it
was not a very good situation and please
note that
more often than not these older guys who
came after three or four atoms
they were
from some big coaching centers of kota
rajasthan
so why is it bad
you see
sure in the big scope of life
two three years of age difference does
not matter much
i mean there is hardly any difference
between a 47 year old man and a 50 year
old man
but in this crucial age of 17 years to
20 years is a very delicate age at this
age
a difference of even one year matters a
lot
because with in the in the scope of this
one year
a lot of mental maturity emotional
maturity can take place in once in one
individual
so
when you have in the same batch
students
who do not have the advantage of this
extra maturity and on the other hand you
have this
much older students it creates a
tremendous gap in their emotional
maturity in the kind of expectations
that they have in the kind of life that
they lead in the kind of interest that
they have
now in the first year of iit life there
are not just new kinds of academic
challenges to confront but there are
also the challenges of adjusting to this
new hostel life of a shared living space
so
students who already have this
experience of two three years beyond
their plus two
of living away from their home
uh they were at a distinct advantage and
i would say some kind of an unfair
advantage please also note that this
kind of an advantage in terms of how
they handle the stress of living away
from their home this sometimes used to
translate into their academic
performance also
but please don't jump to the conclusion
that all the students who came to
uh these older guys who came to iit
after three four attempts they were all
performing well just because they had
learned to handle the stress there is
another aspect to it also which i'll
come a little bit later let me move
forward to the next point which is that
you see these guys these older guys who
were
able to attempt uh three or four times
they were able to do so
only because their parents were
sufficiently well off
to be able to support their uh these
guys in their coaching year after year
so
on the other hand a family of more
modest means that means who are not so
well off they would not have been able
to
support their child
through these years of continuous
coaching
okay so
this was a major major disadvantage
okay like an unfair disadvantage to this
students who are not from affluent
families another point is that
when these guys were coming to iit after
three four atoms they were denying
a seat to a fresh deserving candidate
a candidate who may actually have been
much better than these older guys but
who just happened to got edged out
because these older guys may have picked
up a few extra tips and tricks from
their coaching
or
just because they had a better
examination temperament
because they have been attempting it so
many times so ironically what was
happening was that some of the nits
the uh
a lot of the seats in these nits were
getting filled by genuinely very good
students whereas a non-trivial number of
the seats in iits were getting blocked
by these older guys
now please note my work my words
i've said blocked i i did not say that
they were being occupied by these older
guys because earlier i had said that
there was an unfair advantage to some of
the students
some of these older guys and yes there
was a certain section among them who
came to iit after a lot of effort and
they still maintain those efforts okay
i'm talking about the older guys here
and
even if it is a disadvantage like an
unfair advantage they still put in the
effort they they studied hard
and they did well
but at the same time there were a
significant number of students among
these older guys
who
after
having gone through that extreme grind
of the coaching center for three four
for three or four of their atoms they
had become completely mentally jaded
jaded means they had completely lost
their freshness their mental stamina
they had lost
most of their interest in academics they
were
not at all interested in studying they
practically they just
uh coasted along after coming to iit
and just waiting to get a job and just
went out like that so
now you tell me that if this is not
blocking a seat what is okay so there
were perhaps much more deserving
candidates who were who got to study in
the uh in the nineties and later on they
did very well
okay but they could have studied in in
the iits uh
uh which was perhaps their dream so
these are some of the main points that i
wanted to highlight uh again i emphasize
that these are my
absolutely my personal opinions uh
so
my only hope is that through these
points you will have a better
understanding of why these restrictions
are there
and i also hope sincerely that
if you are attempting
j and j advanced particularly very
seriously
may you be successful in
writing your first attempt and
if you really want to go for your second
attempt will be successful in that so
all the very best thank you